[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
11 novembre le général de gaulle était
au rendez vous de la piété nationale
devant le tombeau du soldat inconnu
entouré des anciens combattants des deux
guerres françaises et alliées le chef de
l'état a commémoré le souvenir de la
victoire de 1918 et en même temps le
souvenir de tous ceux qui tombèrent sur
les champs de bataille
quarante trois ans ont passé depuis la
fin de la grande guerre 43 ans qui ont
vu bien d'autres bouleversements mais le
premier cataclysme mondial fut si énorme
et entraînant des conséquences que près
d'un demi-siècle s'est écoulé sans le
faire oublier
[Musique]
le célèbre pavillon de flore quitte
enfin le service des finances de l'état
pour se mettre à celui des beaux-arts
monsieur baumgartner en a remis
solennellement les clés à monsieur andré
malraux ministre des affaires
culturelles
[Musique]
le pavillon de flore va être aménagée
pour recevoir les collection de
sculptures des 18 et 19ème siècle du
musée du louvre
la fondation de la location dont le jury
réunit à la fois des hommes de lettres
des journalistes des publicistes des
chefs d'entreprise a remis pour la
deuxième fois ses bourses annuelles 26
jeunes gens et jeunes filles ont ainsi
reçu un chèque d'un million d'anciens
francs qui doit leur permettre de
s'aventurer dans de meilleures
conditions dans le métier qu'ils ont
choisi d'exercer tel est en effet le but
de cette oeuvre aider les révocations à
s'épanouit
le ministre de la santé publique
monsieur joseph fontanet s'est vu
présenter le timbre de la nouvelle
campagne anti tuberculeuse 61,62
traitement bien suivi guérison assuré
tel est le thème de cette campagne qui
vise à mettre en garde des malades
contre les dangers auxquels les expose
le manque de persévérance la tuberculose
peut être guéri mais on doit savoir que
seule la cure en sanatorium offre toutes
les garanties d'une guérison totale
permettant un reclassement définitif
dans la vie sociale
[Musique]
et
ses pairs de corse dont la semaine
dernière nous disions qu'il fallait
revoir ses problèmes à la lumière
d'aujourd'hui il ne faut tout de même
pas la simplifier au point d'en faire le
tableau traditionnel qu'on regarde avec
une affection décourager d'accord c'est
un diptyque dont le premier volet sans
doute et celui du criminel inconnue le
catenaccio traînant ses chaînes sous la
cagoule d'un penny temps du vendredi
saint des vieilles femmes en tissu noir
des ruelles et des maquis
[Musique]
il y a aussi du nouveau en corse du
nouveau c'est à dire des projets des
promesses et des expériences sur cette
terre trop bavard pour nourrir ses
enfants on cherche aujourd'hui de
nouveaux champs dans la plaine orientale
des français venus d'algérie et de
tunisie se sont lancés à la conquête
agricole du pays des fermes modèles se
sont élevées et l'on peut imaginer
qu'avec ses récupérations on pourra
compter en corse 80 mille hectares
cultivés c'est à dire le dixième du sol
de l'île c'est pour ainsi dire une corse
nouvelle qui est en train de naître sans
doute cette agriculture ne sera jamais
de taille à faire vivre la corse mais il
lui reste le merveilleux décor qu'on
peut exploiter en y faisant venir les
touristes dans ce domaine il faut créer
l'infrastructure appel et route
et de ce côté aussi des progrès sont en
cours la rénovation des hôtels est
sérieusement encourager même de beaux
hôtels d'un parfait modernisme se sont
élevées
[Musique]
et
déjà aussi le problème routier a été
sérieusement étudiée un réseau de routes
touristiques et ou en projet ou en cours
d'exécution et le voyageur de demain ne
se posera plus la question d'amener avec
lui sa voiture il s'agit de refaire la
corse à l'échelle moderne or l'avenir de
la corse c'est peut-être simplement de
pouvoir montrer ses calanques et ses
vieilles vignes et là dessus son ciel
dès dimanche
[Musique]
c'est à cette force avec ses problèmes
avec aussi ses espérances a cette force
qui n'avait pas reçu la visite d'un
président de la république depuis 40 ans
que le général de gaulle a choisi de
consacrer les premières journées de son
15e voyages en france et bastia comme
ajaccio nous ont réservé le même accueil
un accueil tel que l'avait défini à
l'avancé des personnalités de l'île
chaleureux sans arrière pensée comme
savent le faire les portes et c'est
devant cette foule que le chef de l'état
devait rouvrir le dossier algérien si
personne n'y met deux préalables et nous
n'émettrons aucun la conversation va
s'engager d'un jour à le
[Musique]
la visite du port de marseille a marqué
le début de la quatrième et dernière
journée du voyage présidentiel qui après
la corse avait conduit le chef de l'état
à travers le var et les bouches-du-rhône
à marseille porte de la méditerranée
ouverte sur l'afrique du nord le général
de gaulle devait évoquer à nouveau le
règlement de l'affairé algérienne il
devrait le faire devant une foule
immense
je déclare que la solution du problème
algérien sait que l'algérie dispose de
son destin c'est qu'une coopération soit
établie entre l'algérie nouvelle et la
france
[Musique]
pendant 48 heures l'incendié a fait rage
sur les collines de santa monica le
quartier chic de hollywood deux brasiers
séparés par une distance de 17 km se
précipitaient à la rencontre l'un de
l'autre sur un tronc de 15 km 24
bombardier ont répandu des teintes de
brun les sinistrés star politique comme
monsieur nixon ou star cinématographique
s'efforçait avec les moyens du bord de
défendre leurs habitations et départ
promis le pompier et 1000 soldats
hollywood pour une fois dans sa vie
factice a été confronté avec un incendie
authentique ces menaces ces périls et
ces désastres
aujourd'hui que le danger est passé on
peut évaluer l'ensemble des dégâts 200
villas sont détruites avec tout le luxe
qu'elle contenait peut-être 50 milliards
d'anciens francs réduisent en fumée
[Musique]
comme chaque année moscou a fêté
l'anniversaire de la révolution
d'octobre par un immense défilé
populaire sur la place rouge la fin
officielle du culte de staline a produit
cet effet que l'éffigie de khrouchtchev
a remplacé celle du dictateur défunt
et dans la tribune officielle qui
surmonte le monument d'où le corps de
staline a été enlevée le maître du
kremlin entouré de ses invités étrangers
et des membres du gouvernement a présidé
cette manifestation de masse désormais
classique
[Musique]
détail curieux le maréchal vorochilov
ancien président de l'urss malgré son
humble autocritique au récent congrès
n'a pas été admis à la tribune
officielle
et puis
[Musique]
le mur qui coupent berlin en 2 coupes en
2d famille prétexte d'un grave incident
de la vie internationale il est en même
temps à l'origine de drames familiaux
chaque dimanche on peut voir des groupes
de part et d'autre de cette barrière
aujourd'hui infranchissable se ferme
signe ou plus simplement chercher au
loin un visage amis
triste rencontre où seuls les yeux
peuvent parler
devant l'entrée aujourd'hui muré du
cimetière sainte hedwidge on dépose ce
qu'on ne peut plus déposer comme hier
sur les tombes ne mur ne sépare pas que
les vivants
l'équipe de bulgarie maillot blanc la
rencontre devant la france à sofia
c'était le match de la dernière chance
le match qu'il fallait gagner à
n'importe quel prix les bulgares riom
mille prix en effet ils n'ont pas hésité
à appuyer leur action avec une certaine
rudesse sous l'oeil bienveillant de
larbitre un arbitre que les français ne
sont pas prêts d'oublier
au début du match on craignait le pire
pour l'équipe de france a tort sans
doute puisque toutes les attaques
bulgare devait apporter sur une défense
très efficace
pour les français une seule consigne le
match nul à la mi-temps tous les espoirs
leur sont encore permis
à plusieurs reprises en seconde mi temps
ils ont même le but au bout du pied une
combinaison guillas muller plus vient
aussi sur coup franc et près d'aboutir
mais l'arbitré lui est bien décidé à
offrir la victoire à la bulgarie à une
minute de la fin un bulgare commettent
une faute dans le camp français qu'à
cela ne tienne coup franc pour la
bulgarie le coup franc ne donne rien pas
de chance deal arbitres on va leur jouer
à ce petit jeu les bulgares finissent
par gagner et on se demande encore ce qu
aurait fait l'arbitré si les bulgares
n'avait pas profiter de son cadeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]